hey guys I'm Abby char welcome to Abby's
kitchen it is back to work in school
time so I partnered up with Nano yogurt
who sponsored this video to help you
nail the school lunch game I've been
getting a lot of questions about this on
social media
so I want to jump in here's a note that
I got from my family
dear Abby I've got two kids at two very
different life stages my son is in grade
eight who has a monster appetite and my
daughter is just her a great one I also
have to pack a lunch my husband and I so
we don't just go ahead and grab fast
food every single day at work the work
week is hectic enough so the thought of
having to make multiple meals to suit
everyone's nutritional needs and
preferences is legit keeping me up at
night any ideas on how to attack this
back to school piece signed lunch
stressed flip Palin I only have one kid
and I definitely don't need to be
packing cama lunchbox anytime soon but I
can totally commiserate with your
concern sometimes just packing one lunch
can seem like a drag so I've developed a
really easy strategy to help you feed
your kids your team and yourself all
with the same healthy ingredients one
meal free way let's do this first off
let's talk about the building blocks
my goal is variety and an easy way to
achieve that is to think about getting
in all the different food groups so that
means fruits and vegetables grains dairy
and alternatives and meat and
alternatives and I'm using nano cheese
and yogurt for a dairy and alternatives
I'm a big fan of these Nano mozzarella
cheese packs because they're all-natural
they come in single easy to open
packages and they're available in 21 fun
animal designs for kids the Nano yogurt
is also a really great snack option
because this thing with no refined sugar
added state eating whole milk and 1
billion probiotics now let's pack some
lunches for our little I like to pack
all these flavors as finger foods bento
box style so it's super easy for kids to
pick up the meat on
we've got sliced baby tomatoes diced
avocado black beans and homemade whole
grain tortillas I've sliced into
triangles and baked with a touch of
olive oil and salt for dessert we've got
diced mango and nano yogurt for a
healthy treat lastly as the snacks pop
in a nano mozzarella cheese
for our preteens and teens we need
something a little more substantial
so tex-mex rap it is in tow whole grain
rap I add lettuce black beans sliced
bell peppers tomatoes and sliced avocado
wrap everything up tightly into the
tortilla
[Music]
Boozer is nanos big sister
Yoko protein yogurt public mango and
some coconut chips packs both the
burrito and the EO Co protein parfait
along with a healthy beverage for your
growing team and now it's Archer I try
to get a big salad in at least once a
day and taco salad is always a fan
favorite first I'm gonna make the
dressing to a small container I add the
olive oil lime juice and the honey
season with a pinch of salt and give it
a good shake to our salad I start with
some lettuce add some tomatoes bell
peppers avocado black beans and homemade
tortilla chips
[Music]
I'm packing this delicious tex-mex salad
up with the same yoga protein per se we
made for a hungry team
don't forget the dressing and a decaf
latte with 2% milk
it's the perfect pick-me-up for that
free PS well well in I hope this meal
becomes a staple in your family's
routine it's definitely one of my
favorites and honestly will make your
lunch assembly a total breeze well guys
if you love this video be sure to give
it a thumbs up leave me a comment below
if some of your back-to-school struggles
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
you
[Music]